SPEAKER: OK, so
let's get started.
So there are a lot
of materials here.
What I was preparing
is that I think
I'm going to go
through some of them
and leave about 10 minutes.
I'd like to go over
some of the samples
to how see how the scenes line
up with Google [? Stores. ?]
Question-wise, after we finish,
I think that we are so--
based on the number of you, we
can have a very intimate talk.
So whenever you guys have
questions, you can stop.
And also this one
is the last one.
So I think time pressure
is not that big.
Yeah, I've got to say that.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK, here we go.
So the topic of here
today is the performance
of 3D graphics for Android.
[INAUDIBLE] It's kind of just
to give you an overview of what
Vulkan looks like.
There's no [INAUDIBLE]
sessions, you can [INAUDIBLE].
Vulkan, it's kind over
the top in that way.
OK, this is the first slide.
The first thing on the left.
His name is Jesse.
He's the main person
behind Android graphics.
So on the right is the
red book from Khronos.
That's a tradition, Khronos
always publishes a book.
[INAUDIBLE]
So last week, I asked
them, do you need
me to talk about the future.
Maybe check whether you
guys have NDA with Khronos.
Oh, let me ask, how many of
you have an NDA with Khronos.
Just within Khronos group.
your NDA [INAUDIBLE].
Just an agreement.
A shared agreement, whatever
I talk, if I talk the future,
whatever I talk,l then you guys
only keep this in to yourself.
You have something
signed with Khronos.
Well, I better not talk
anything in the future.
But I don't know too
much about the future.
It's fine.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, let me talk to you
today about [INAUDIBLE].
[? So many ?] said why?
Why Vulkan?
What is it, and how can I get
started on Vulkan Android.
And the last two is,
hopefully the last one
after you hear the first two,
the problem is already solved.
Otherwise I didn't
do a good work.
So the first one is
a very important one.
So some tips from partners
we worked with in the past.
So my focus will be
on the first three.
The fourth one, I will
kick off with three topics.
from it, [INAUDIBLE]
So why don't we start over.
So let's look at the
vertical timeline.
So look at this.
Back to 1992, the first
version of OpenGL released.
The computing world
is like this--
486.
That's Windows 3.1.
Windows 3.1, looking at
the history, looking back,
it's a very important one.
To me, that is beginning of
the green industry [INAUDIBLE]
or applications,
computing work, together.
[INAUDIBLE] In those days,
there's no such thing as a GPU.
All you had is a
[INAUDIBLE], basically,
a scan line, just a display.
30 or 40 registers
for the right,
and you get the digital mapping.
You can put in the memory
[INAUDIBLE] for the image you
want to display and then write
the register for the timings,
and then you do the [? DA ?]
[? transformation. ?]
That's all.
Looking at it today, so mobile
CPUs today look like this.
On CPU size, these are the CPUs.
So CPUs now all
have multiple cores.
This is the mobile.
We are not talking
about desktop yet.
For desktop, you have
even more powerful.
So all the [INAUDIBLE]
all have a cache.
They all have the multiple
cores running at the same time.
And look at the power
and clock speed.
So we see here, what I'm trying
to say is, mathematically, I
think this one is [INAUDIBLE].
And I think, comparing
to a 3D thing,
this is the simplest
one, the [INAUDIBLE].
So what it is trying
to say over here
is that the
multi-core is helping
for the power consumption.
So by looking at the line
over here, it's a 2.2,
where the frequency over here,
with one core, it's over here.
Some are here.
So now it's about 1.6 watts.
Looking at the dual
core, so this second one,
if I ran a dual core
at 1.1, so I'm here,
I'm [? currently ?] using about
less than half of the power.
So that point of here is
that by using multi-core,
you really can save
power for the system.
And now we have GPUs.
So GPUs, you can
look at the GPUs
and have [INAUDIBLE]
[? one sharing ?] unit how
this is done inside the chip.
Now in any of the GPUs
in use nowadays, we
can easily get to 32.
Now, on desktop,
it's [? in solids. ?]
So you can see the computing
power change in these 20 years
or so.
So with this
happening, there need
to be new things, new APIs to
address the parallelization
to use these multi-cores.
GPU [? set, ?] it's OK.
It's already done.
Because GPU, you have shares.
Shares [INAUDIBLE] GPU.
The shares need
[INAUDIBLE] to [INAUDIBLE].
So that part is taken care of.
The other part that needs to
be taken care of [INAUDIBLE]
is the CPU set, the
parallelization.
So to help address that, there
is no silver bullet for this
yet.
So a lot of people have been
trying to get a generic library
to this.
But in the end, is--
yeah, it's kind of
like wait in line
lower level API [INAUDIBLE].
Developers, let
them decide what is
the best for their application.
Because only application
knows what is the best things
they do.
And with that, they know how
to address those problems.
[INAUDIBLE] memory
[INAUDIBLE] processing.
So that is the
industry, [INAUDIBLE].
Now, by looking at the
[INAUDIBLE], iOS, 2014,
they released that.
Anybody writing programs on iOS?
So same thing, a similar
story on Windows.
On Windows side,
the [? dx ?] is also
released around
the same timeframe.
So those OS, the two
major non-open source
OS, they all have
their own solutions.
So you can imagine.
Open source is
[INAUDIBLE] left behind.
So open is the answer to this.
So Vulkan is used by, they're
mainly targeting for all OS's.
That's the [INAUDIBLE].
Vulkan, [? what it does, ?]
it does its best.
It's targeted for
all [INAUDIBLE].
You can use all the
four major OS's.
But later on, there's
a [INAUDIBLE] for that.
For Android, Vulkan is the
primary runner [INAUDIBLE].
So that's why Vulkan is here.
Now, let's get into Vulkan.
So what are the major
Vulkan features for us?
Everybody is using
these new API standards.
So on iOS, they
have their own ones.
And [? dx ?] have
their own ones.
Vulkan, when it does it,
it does it for everybody.
So the features from
Vulkan is explicit.
Explicit means, if it's
OpenGL, for example,
if you don't use something,
you don't have to set it.
[INAUDIBLE] default for it.
Here, anything you use,
you need to [INAUDIBLE].
You need to set it to something.
But as soon as
you don't need it,
you need to initialize
it [? for yourself. ?]
It's all [INAUDIBLE]
application.
Those things are not
specific for Vulkan either.
It applies to all
these three major
rendering engines [INAUDIBLE].
[? Dx, ?] similar thing.
So this, this [? visit ?] is
kind of the industry standard.
It's a trend we
are moving toward.
So more than we are going to
see later for those [INAUDIBLE],
and another very important
one is extensible.
So this extensibility
is very important,
and is kind of a
traditional tool for Kronos.
Kronos open stacks,
not only for graphics.
So OpenGL [INAUDIBLE]
have the interface
designed for extensions,
so those kind of things.
So now let's look at
what explicit means.
By looking at this graph,
we can see from OpenGL,
in driver is a [? fat ?] driver.
The driver needs to
handle a lot of things.
Driver gives you
abstraction layers
and in context management.
Memory allocation come
here a lot of times
here share GL
[? SAL ?] compiler.
And the validation
error checking
is one we'll also
going to come back to.
And that is an
important portion of it.
Now all this, you've got to push
it over to application work.
So you really have the power
to do whatever you want,
basically.
You have [INAUDIBLE].
The layer here is very thin.
Basically it's just one wrapper
for the [? analyst ?] hardware.
So the rest is all yours.
So you can [? replicate ?]
every single cycle from the GPU,
with these explicit APIs.
So the benefit with explicit
APIs is, in a sense,
you already know what is going
to happen in your program
because the driver
there is so thin,
it then draws too
much processing.
So everything,
almost everything,
is in your application code.
So there is-- you
know, definitely you
know what is going to
happen at which time.
So that brings you
predictable behavior
and predictable performance.
Back [? on there is ?] OpenGL,
it has to reach to a dual core
to know how to
parallelize these things.
Now moving on to the next one.
[INAUDIBLE] design for desktop
and mobile [? cores ?] OS.
So [INAUDIBLE] is a
big feature for this.
So right now, core standard
is the same for all OS's.
The only [INAUDIBLE]
that are different
is the WSI portion of it,
Windows System Interface.
So how do you present?
Once you get a draw, you
get [INAUDIBLE] system.
That porting is separate.
But it's part.
If you got to the Khronos, you
will see that standard, WSI.
So that [INAUDIBLE]
is heavily native OS,
whatever OS it is, you need
to use that OS mechanism.
So when the OS is
ported to Vulkan,
it will provide this service.
So that brings a lot of
good things for [INAUDIBLE].
Most of your code,
for Vulkan, or most--
99%, I think, is close to that.
So all of them can be
directly used on all the OS's.
You develop it for
Windows Vulkan,
you [? can use ?] for
[INAUDIBLE] Linux, Vulkan,
and for Android.
For iOS, there is a Vulkan VT.
That company already [INAUDIBLE]
have a wrapper for Vulkan
to run on top of iOS.
We have a demo on
[INAUDIBLE] [? earlier. ?]
Next big picture for
this is [INAUDIBLE].
One of the major things
Vulkan is trying to address
is CPU use in
parallel processing.
This is for that.
So how do these
[? multi-processing ?] work
is-- for example, if you
recommend the buffers,
you can have separate
threads on CPU.
We're talking about the
CPU thread, on CPU thread.
You can have several
[INAUDIBLE] view
command buffers for that scene.
In another thread
you can run buffers
for another thing in the
frame, in a single frame.
Then you can let them submit the
command into the command queue.
So of course, you need to handle
the syncronization or portion
of it, because it
might [INAUDIBLE] share
in the same queue.
But those are kind of
traditional programming stuff.
This leads to the next for us.
That's the example.
So in this example, here's
the [? force ?] [? array, ?]
and viewing different command
buffers [INAUDIBLE] the same
command queue.
This over here, when
you submit, it's
your responsibility to provide
synchronization [INAUDIBLE]
your queue.
OK, so next, we said
[INAUDIBLE] is the graphics
and the computer also put in a
[INAUDIBLE], all of this talk
is about graphics.
And another one is the SPIR.
So SPIR in OpenGL have
GL as a [INAUDIBLE].
You gave to OpenGL.
It will compile at runtime.
And you [INAUDIBLE]
to meet over there.
So we see compile is at runtime.
But Vulkan always
specifies what is
the [INAUDIBLE] representation.
It's called intermediate
representation.
This is for [INAUDIBLE].
But that is the lower
level, lower level
than GL as [INAUDIBLE].
And it can be compiled offline.
It doesn't have to be
compiled at runtime.
So the benefit that is some of
the games, when you compile,
it takes a long time, so
it can cause a glitch.
But with this one, you
can compile it offline,
and directly through
Vulkan, then these glitches
can get removed.
So remember, 2007, [INAUDIBLE].
At that time, I was
not working at Google.
So the tool to do the
[INAUDIBLE] translate
your [INAUDIBLE]
GLSL [INAUDIBLE]
or the high level language
to [? SPIR, ?] it's yours.
It's your applications.
So the responsibility
can do whatever you want.
So just to translate for
[INAUDIBLE] that's all.
So from Google we
have a tool called
[INAUDIBLE] to help you to
do this compiling translation
[INAUDIBLE].
You don't have to use it.
So you can do your
own [INAUDIBLE]
optimization over
these kinds of things.
The major thing nowadays, is
the battle is in the shader.
What decides whether you
have the best application,
those things is in the shader.
OK, so this slide over here,
[INAUDIBLE] it's from Khronos.
So this is talking
about the pipeline, what
the pipeline looks like and then
how the buffers get submitted
to the pipeline at which point.
So this booklet is from Khronos
before I came I contacted them.
They sent it to me so
I brought it over here.
So you guys can feel
free to pick it up.
It's right there on the table.
The point here, I think, is if
you are doing Vulkan rendering,
get familiar with
these kinds of help
when you are coding
your own application.
So put it that way.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Yeah, this one is like a forest.
So Vulkan [INAUDIBLE]
is a big subject.
When you focus on something,
that one is kind of a leaf.
I might have said it wrong.
So we're talking about the
extensibility of Vulkan.
Vulkan is designed in layers.
So the layers is
loaded by loader,
and the interface
is well-defined,
across for all of
the supported OS's.
So [? it's our ?] OS, just
implement those entries
[? full order. ?] And
you design your layers,
then it will be
automatically loaded.
[INAUDIBLE] once you deep drill,
[INAUDIBLE] it'll be uploaded.
What they're good for the
layers and [? continuing. ?]
So if the layers give you a
good [? starting space. ?]
If you want to
extend, there's some
of the value added
from the Vulkan,
then this is the
interface you use.
And also, for
hardware vendors, you
have your new hardware features.
It's not available
in standard yet,
layers and extensions
are your friend.
Off subject a little
bit, I think following
a standard is a good thing.
I think a better thing is
[? ahead of ?] standard.
The industry is standard
serving the industry,
not industry creates a standard.
Whatever the standard
is, the industry
has already moved ahead of that.
So if you want to do something,
hopefully, you will really
do something that
[? eventually ?] is ahead
of standard, then
your features move
into the standard, not only for
technical stuff, [INAUDIBLE]
also for the first
time getting to market
for some kind of
thing like that.
I know it's off from
today's subject.
So with those layers, so you can
extend the Vulkan at any time.
When I give you an
example for this
is looking at one of the major
uses for layers right now
is [INAUDIBLE].
So where we talk about,
in OpenGL applications,
there's a lot of validated
code in your parameter
if correct or not.
If not, then do something.
If we're correct, then
you still check, right?
Because that cycle is wasted.
If your [? picture ?]
is well behaved,
those cycles are wasted.
Now the Vulkan model is this.
You can take out this.
You're going to take out
those validation things out
of this Vulkan driver.
It's not part of that anymore.
You take it out, then
put them into layers.
Later on, we have a
big section for that.
We have seven layers right now.
So we have all
validations in layers,
and you plug it in, easy.
Plug it in and show that.
Then you write application.
Anything like parameters
wrong or something set
is [? draw image ?] not
in a correct format,
then those kind of things get
caused by a broken validation
in layers [INAUDIBLE].
So after your application
gets [INAUDIBLE] well debugged
and well validated, you
are ready to deploy,
this is the model you go.
You just don't load
the validation layers.
All the cycles you
used to waste over here
are used for your application.
So that's why I said you can
get every cycle of your GPU
to your application.
Here we are, CPU set is simple.
[INAUDIBLE]
So core loader interface,
we talked about that.
[INAUDIBLE], one interface
is used across the board.
Loader interface is
easier than this.
It's well-defined, and for all
the OS, it's the same thing.
But for Android, the loader--
all of these loaders
are kind of a part of OS
for Android is the OS component.
See Vulkan is an open standard.
So that is another
advantage here for Vulkan.
Before [INAUDIBLE]
it's open source.
It's [? for ?]
all the OS to use.
And it provides
for specifications
and [? confirm this ?] test.
Specification is for
application developers
and also for the GPU developers.
Because from here it's spec.
And your developers are
going to use the spec
to develop applications.
For [INAUDIBLE] Qualcomm
and [INAUDIBLE],
they also need to know what
the expectation is to implement
all the required features.
They normally do more than
just standard requests.
So the [INAUDIBLE] test is
meant to be used for the GPU
[? writers. ?] So once they
have the GPU on the system,
then they need to parse
the [? performance ?] test.
The [? component ?] test is
designed to offer the committee
and the media driving
for component test is
[? from Google. ?]
And there's also tools, a
set of tools available like
[INAUDIBLE].
All these tools are available.
They are all GitHub.
And last but not least
is the validation errors.
Validation errors are
designed by [INAUDIBLE].
It's developed by [INAUDIBLE].
And [INAUDIBLE]
is part of Google.
So it's part of
Google's support.
So we're going to talk about
validation layers later on.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
support with [INAUDIBLE].
And the macOS [INAUDIBLE]
media supported,
use the plugin wrapper.
If you go to YouTube,
you'll find it.
OK, with all these
good things, how do we
start with Vulkan
development on Android?
So there's a video, this
one, I actually skipped it.
So we can save some
time for later.
So this is [? when I recorded ?]
this one to Android.
I'm going to skip this.
So to do Vulkan,
we need a device.
So emulator is not
supported in Vulkan yet.
So we need a device to test
out the Vulkan applications.
So when Vulkan was released
in May, this set of devices
was supported on Android.
Now there are more.
And you need an OS,
of course, right?
Android N is the first OS
baked in for Vulkan support.
And you need another
set of tools.
Android Studio is easiest
for the development.
Oh yeah, how many of you are
from the game engine companies?
Writing game engines?
So normally, game
engine companies,
they have their own IDEs.
Android Studio, download
latest Android Studio.
And Android Studio will download
SDK for you, which that is easy
[INAUDIBLE].
SDK with the OS, then all the
OS Android all have these.
The library all
built in already.
And once you go over to
your old application,
then you will need header
files and the library,
the [? lib stop. ?]
It's not a full library.
This is dynamically linked.
So library stuff
is all inside NDK.
From Release 12 and up.
Then Vulkan is pretty big API.
So some samples already baked.
You can look at those samples.
And it is helpful for [? to ?]
get [INAUDIBLE] started.
This is a set of
one file samples.
Each sample just
includes one file.
And in the file is
tried to illustrate
how to use that one API.
Each one is one [INAUDIBLE].
And this is how you generate.
You see [? make ?] generate
the Android studio project
for those samples.
And right now, if you get the
source code from the repo,
you don't have to do this.
Everything is checked
in from this repo.
So this one, you
don't have to do it.
And then you can import
the generated samples
into Android Studio [INAUDIBLE].
There's been a [INAUDIBLE]
for the samples of the--
basic samples you see from
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
device, and all
the major APIs you
needed to use to create
one application, one
simple application [INAUDIBLE].
So to draw a [? queue, ?] in
the graphics rendering stacks,
normally people
say, how do I draw
my first triangle
this is the way
to draw your first triangle.
[INAUDIBLE] triangles.
So then you have a next
[? range ?] that add
in the textures, get a
texture [? queue. ?] So
the recommendation
is [INAUDIBLE].
And to see what's
going on there,
then you get some feeling of it.
It's like [INAUDIBLE].
I don't think you
have to follow that.
Geniuses never
follow other people.
That's why you guys
are called geniuses.
So with that, we get
into the next one
is tips for what do
we learn from partners
and from ourselves when
we [INAUDIBLE] Vulkan.
So mostly from partners
working with us.
So from these, there are a
lot of materials from here.
So I'm going to
skip some of this.
I will pick up three from them.
The three I think
is very pressing.
These three would be
what I feel is important.
So the first one, it doesn't
have a lot of materials.
First one is the
validation layers.
You've got to use that one.
You've used that one
as he must use too.
So what the validation
layers does [INAUDIBLE]
is check all the possible
errors from your application.
So that is going to save
you a lot of trouble.
Vulkan, by the way, if
anything set is wrong,
it's going to crash your system.
We said before, it is explicit.
Anything you use, you set it.
If you don't set it, it's
going to take whatever garbage
in there, right?
And you can imagine that
it's going [INAUDIBLE].
This one goes down [INAUDIBLE]
to the GPU, to the [INAUDIBLE].
It's a very low
level. iOS [? used ?]
their other team over here,
they do the presentations.
They have a large [INAUDIBLE]
for the prompt for the Android
[INAUDIBLE].
There are a lot of
prompts to choose from.
Vulkan is going a different way.
They give you everything
you can possibly have.
The choice is all
yours from yourself.
Validation errors is
going to the rescue
for a lot of troubles.
So we talked about it already.
The detector reports
errors and also
points out performance issues.
So, so far, the
[INAUDIBLE] is important.
[INAUDIBLE]
So the partners working
with us, they all
have good feedback for the
Vulkan validation errors.
It's like a must.
OK validation errors is
important [INAUDIBLE].
So there are three
places to get it.
That slide over
here, by the way,
is a little bit different
from slides [INAUDIBLE]
from the conference, I
modified portion a little bit.
So the industry one for
you to use is from NDK.
The validation layers is
packed inside NDK from NDK 3.0
and above.
Later on, we can open
and try to have a look.
So it's in that directory.
We have preview layers, or
[INAUDIBLE] directly usage.
Or if you want to have
some more hands on it,
later on we can show
you [INAUDIBLE].
So as far as I know,
it's the [INAUDIBLE].
[? Layers ?] together
with your application
with the [INAUDIBLE]
at same time,
so the symbols would set
out correctly for your IDE,
so you can trace the code
from your application
into the validating layers.
Now this one over here is the--
Khronos group is the real
source for all the validation
layers on the GitHub.
So you see any GitHub
copy we get, normally when
NDK released, then,
at release time,
we get a selection
[INAUDIBLE] for NDK to upload.
And there are other providers
in these original [? four ?]
is Lunar G samples,
and those are all
coming from the Khronos place.
How do you build
validation layers?
So validation layers is
built with NDK builder.
So your NDK builder
is always there.
And in R12, you can use
[? a grade or ?] experimental.
How many of you guys hear about
[? grade or ?] experimental?
OK.
So I will skip over that part.
So in NDK 13,
[INAUDIBLE] took out
[? the grade or ?]
experimental portion of it.
So that one brings Android
Studio 2.2 release,
it supports NDK build natively.
That's disabled without
a [? password. ?]
Once you build, you will need
to [INAUDIBLE] into the NDKs
together with your
application so they can
be loaded during the runtime.
And that is
[INAUDIBLE] load from.
[INAUDIBLE] how do we
enable validation layers
in your application that is
on your application source
code-wise.
You have this thing
available [INAUDIBLE] target.
Then you're inside
your application.
How do you hook up to it?
How do you get it to track?
To track your application,
this is the way.
For all the layers, put them
into these instance layers.
When you create instance, you'll
give him that layer array name.
Name is the [? only one ?]
that it will use.
Validation layers and the
extensions all have a name.
The name is a string.
It's 8-bit characters
not UTF or 16.
So you give him the layers
and the total count of layers.
And then you'll go ahead
and create an instance.
The layers will
trigger for the loader
to load if you try to
create an instance.
You have that loaded.
How do you use it?
Because you loaded it.
Yeah, then that's good.
Then when the validation
layers find some errors,
how does one bring to
interact [INAUDIBLE]?
This is the way.
You need to register for
some mechanism over here
that this, well-defined,
is the callback.
You implement a callback
function defined like this.
And you also need to register
to the Vulkan [INAUDIBLE].
Yes, I have a callback.
I have one registered.
Whenever there is any
error, call my function.
So we're going to
open the source
code to have a look at it.
Beyond the validations,
so this portion here
works as a testing,
[INAUDIBLE] Vulkan
is the cross of the platforms.
Now desktop, most
new GPUs, it's got
to be from the [INAUDIBLE] half
from the middle of last year.
So those new GPUs, it's going
to support Vulkan on desktop.
The other thing is
that you go to GPU
and there's a place to check
[? out, ?] they will have.
If they support Vulkan, they
will show you that [INAUDIBLE].
And you can use those platforms
to validate your Vulkan code.
So if you feel mobile
device [? management ?]
is a little bit too
hard, you know, too
time consuming, you can do
that, use that platform,
then you use some
other IDEs to validate
the majority of your code.
Then [INAUDIBLE] the portion
that is Android-specific
can be tested later on.
The second element here
is is the kind of caution.
Vulkan is still new.
For a standard [INAUDIBLE]
to mature takes some time.
So the writers also-- a
new standard coming out,
all the people try to
understand and gradually get it
to the same understanding.
So this is new to everyone.
So when it's new to
everybody [INAUDIBLE],
there can be different
interpretations
for this standard.
So error can happen.
So when you validate
the [INAUDIBLE] errors,
we saw the [INAUDIBLE] document.
Yeah, so be prepared and,
if you see some errors,
report to the GPU owners
and try to find out
what went wrong for it to,
so get yourself [? code. ?]
Distribute Vulkan, [INAUDIBLE]
so Vulkan, [INAUDIBLE].
Android applications,
we have one APK
targeted for all the
architecture like [INAUDIBLE]
or MIPS, if you want.
All these things can
be in one package.
For that package can get
too big when you get people
to download to their phone.
It might be just user error
for this one architecture.
So libraries not used
it's [INAUDIBLE] that
is solution for that.
You split those APKs into
different, multiple APKs.
So each one addresses
each architecture,
though there are
some other criteria.
If you do this in
Vulkan is one of it.
You can say that my APKs,
my application for this APK
version, I need Vulkan.
Then when user downloads
from a place [INAUDIBLE],
if that platform
doesn't support Vulkan,
it will not download that one
but download the other one.
In the future, there might
be another fine granularity
for this, it's which
version of Vulkan
is needed for your application.
A little bit in the future.
I'm not supposed to
talk about the future.
OK, just a little
bit [INAUDIBLE].
On Android, [INAUDIBLE], so if
you [? don't ?] want to see it,
you can ask Android
compositor to do the rotation.
That will end up
[? bleeding extra. ?]
So you need extra [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, OK.
So we need to quickly
go through this.
With the Vulkan [INAUDIBLE]
with one [INAUDIBLE]
you're saving a lot of stuff.
OK, so major thing
with this I want
to see talk about this one.
Multi-pass is another feature,
but GPU rendering on mobile
is all tile-based.
So what is the tile?
Direct rendering, I will leave
you guys to find out later.
So what this is trying to tell
you here is with multi-pass,
is you have a
multi-pass application.
You build single
rendering parts,
and put all the paths
into a submit path.
So you [? give the ?]
GPU with one submit,
and it will do all that drawing
for that build at one time.
So in that case, it's good.
It doesn't have to bring
memory back and forth any more,
so it will save you a
lot of waiting time.
So that brings you
processing power.
So benefits, those things.
This is another [? matrix use ?]
of memory management.
Vulkan assumes the application
will have your own video memory
manager for all memories.
And for host memory,
it's kind of recommended.
It's recommended but
for video memory,
is [INAUDIBLE] [? erase. ?]
So you need your
own memory manager.
Mandatory for your
application, what memory
size you use more often,
and what type of memory
you used more.
So you can do this by
yourselves to maximize the usage
within the memory limit.
OK.
So some tips are [INAUDIBLE]
allocation memories
and what are the tips for
effective memory management.
OK multi-threading
we talked about that.
It is important, you must do it.
So that is a major feature
for Vulkan [INAUDIBLE].
With multithreading
and [INAUDIBLE].
I think that's all we
want to cover for this.
Now we can take a couple
of minutes right now
and show some of the code.
We are in the last session here.
If you guys need to leave,
then feel free to leave.
Nobody will kick us out.
So I'd like to show some of
the things, in Android studio,
how the thing is
done in the samples.
Yeah, feel free to leave.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]